Miley Cyrus you know I'm a Miley fan
I mean I don't listen to her music I
don't really listen to any modern music
but I kind of get a kick out of her
because she says things that are at
least contrary to what the Liberals
always believe sometimes and I think
she's got a good voice and I always
loved Party in the USA so here is Miley
Cyrus explaining her divorce
I have to slow down because this is like
actually serious so Glastonbury was in
June which was when the decision had
been made that
me and Liam's commitment to being
married just really came from of course
a place of Love first because we've been
together for 10 years but also from a
place of trauma and just trying to
rebuild as quickly as we could the day
of the show was the day that I had
decided that it was no longer going to
work in my life to be in that in that
relationship so that was another moment
where the work the performance the
character came first and I guess that's
why it's now so important to me
for that to not be the case that the
human comes first
notice how clinical and controlled Miley
is here if you're listening to this and
I bring up the story not because I care
about celebrity gossip with Miley Cyrus
but because it it tells you a lot about
how to engage in society and a lot about
how our political order works
Miley is reading off an iPad she's she's
got her words written out perfectly here
and she's being very controlled she goes
and I and that was the moment at which I
decided that this relationship was not
going to work in my life and it's all
this really vague clinical language but
then she says she goes look I've always
just worked okay
and the show must go on and I was
working and I was working too much and
I I think she's implying here the reason
her marriage fell apart is because she
and her husband just were too focused on
their careers and just always put
their work which is Show Business
first
above everything else and I think that's
what a lot of people do
a lot of people put their jobs first
that's a cause of a lot of marital
strain
a lot of people put their careers first
and their education and their settling
into their professional life first
that's why they don't get married until
sometimes it's too late or it's much
more difficult to get married this is
why they don't have kids they put off
having kids until very often it's too
late and it's a it's a lie
it's it's a scam and they come to regret
it and the the people who get suckered
in by even something that seems Noble
you know getting on your hustle and
working hard and putting the show first
even they will come to regret that very
often
because you want to work hard and you
want to be serious in your professional
life and you want to have good material
means but that's not everything
right now text Knowles to 98 98 98
Vladimir Putin called the US Dollars
drop in dominance quote objective and
irreversible as Brazil Russia India
China and South Africa formally agreed
to use local currencies in trade instead
of the US dollar as demand for the
dollar weakens the buying power of the
dollar weakens that is why Birch gold is
busier than ever investors and Savers
are looking to harness the power of
physical gold held in attack sheltered
Ira you can too
you can protect your IRA or 401K by
diversifying with gold from Birch gold
as the US dollar continues to receive
pressure from foreign countries digital
currency and central banks arm yourself
with information on how to protect your
savings learn if gold is right for you
too text Knowles Canada wlie Esther 98
98 98 they will send you a free info kit
on gold with an A plus rating with the
Better Business Bureau thousands of
happy customers and countless five-star
reviews I trust Birch gold to help you
diversify into gold if Central Bank
digital currency becomes a reality it
will be nice
to have some gold to depend on right now
text Knowles Canada wies to 98 98 98 you
want to put on a good show everybody's
performing these days not only are we at
the point of society where everyone's
going to be famous for 15 minutes
everyone is famous at least at a local
level
whenever they want to be because we're
always all performing for tick tock and
Instagram and Snapchat and Facebook and
whatever Twitter
so we're always performing sometimes we
put that show first and this reminds me
of a line
that a Dante professor of mine told me
once in Italy you know I was brief in my
wayward youth I was briefly a
professional actor and this Dante
professor of mine he said you know yes
I uh I wanted to be an actor as a young
boy I too good to see her very seriously
my mother discouraged it she told me
there's the door you want to be an actor
there's the door but I thought about it
I I felt so sorry for him and I said oh
no
Professor you you never got to be an
actor you never got to live out your
dream and he said
[Music]
I used to want to be an actor but now I
am the real thing
and I love that line I use that line
yeah yeah I used to be an actor now I'm
the real thing and it's better to be the
real thing it's very nice to play a
married
woman on a sitcom or in a movie
I'm sure Miley Cyrus enjoys doing that
it is better to actually be a wife and a
mother
it's better to be the real thing
it's true for men too I'm sure it's fun
being arrived never been a rock star but
I'm sure it's fun to be a rock star and
to play this this kind of character
where you're just beloved by everybody
it's better to be beloved by your family
who actually
will continue to care for you once the
music dies down
where that where that where that's a
deeper kind of
love and commitment and reality it's
better to be
the real thing Meghan Markle gave up
being an actual princess so that she
could audition to try to play princesses
in Hollywood
that's how backwards our society we love
the semblance of the thing but we're so
afraid of the reality of it because
we're afraid of commitment because we're
afraid of commitment not just to another
person not just to uh circumstances in a
home and a place but a commitment even
to
an idea even to the truth
so we go out and we perform even modern
Spirit spirituality you know we make
these vague gestures about the universe
man you know and like the spirits and
The Vibes and but we don't actually
commit to religious belief because that
would then impose certain obligations on
us
because if you really think that you
know your prayers do something then it
that raises the question well how do
they do something who hears our prayers
who answers our prayers what does what
does he God demand of us as a result
uh of of that line of thinking theology
which is Faith seeking understanding we
don't want any of that so we just keep
making these half-hearted gestures we
just keep playing roles in movies in on
Tick Tock in our daily lives
and that will leave us empty the show is
good
but the real thing is a lot better now
speaking of The Show Must Go On
got some good news a few days ago I'm
finally getting it to it now
you remember
in the spring I I gave a talk at the
University of Pittsburgh and this was
protested it was it was the last in a
series of talks one was with my
colleague Cabot Phillips one was with
Riley Gaines my fellow Tennessean
and then the final one was me and the
the left in Pittsburgh and Pennsylvania
was very upset that I was speaking
because at CPAC I made a comment that
was obviously true and uh which the libs
were Furious about but it's a comment
that I'm not allowed to say on YouTube I
think you know which one I'm talking
about
you know that eradication from public
life entirely and so there were
something like 11 000 signatures against
my coming the university tried to shut
it down the local politicians tried to
shut it down antifa terrorists tried to
shut it down by throwing explosive at
the building while we were walking on
stage still though we were able to go on
they kept threatening they set the
street on fire they were rioting at the
very end of our of our debate
the cops basically rushed us off stage
and out of the building so we had to
cancel the meet and greet had to cancel
some events we had afterward and then
the University of Pittsburgh tried to
punish the college Republicans
for having the audacity to host Me by
charging them an eighteen thousand
dollar almost nineteen thousand dollar
security fee and uh isi the group that
brought me the intercollegal Studies
Institute and the college Republicans
they fought back really hard and Pitt
got a lot of bad press and now they are
no longer requiring the CRS to pay that
fee that fee was effectively
a conservatives on-campus fee that was
the fee to say hey we're a public
university and we're not allowed to stop
you from bringing ordinary conservatives
to campus but we're gonna we're gonna
punish you for it we're gonna bankrupt
you if you ever actually do it and so it
was very important that pit back down
and those jerks over a pit finally
called Uncle and that's great news and
it's great news especially because my
new speech season is approaching we're
launching it this month I'll give you
the full rundown of schools in a few
weeks we got some great schools this
semester
we're going to launch it September 26th
at Georgetown so if you're in Washington
DC
head on over I think you can reserve
tickets now uh so go go check it out
I'll see in DC and please don't throw
any explosives at me and if you do I
hope Georgetown doesn't try to charge us
all like 20 grand just for uh
just for having ducked and missed the
explosive boy what a great clip that was
now make sure that you ring that Bell
subscribe to the Michael Knowles YouTube
channel see you next time